hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica and good
morning Aurora how are you doing Oh
still dead oh that's so sad
I'm alone here I have no friends left
they're all dead
hahahaha anyway welcome back to
subnautica so we were in a bit of a
crisis last time and I rushed away from
that crash site because I was dying I
know I left a lot of things number one I
left the PDA but number two I left the
vehicle modification station which I can
only assume is now the new name for the
seamoth modification station which is
what I need to put in the moonpool to be
able to make what I need to make but
before that I'm about to die so I have
to go into the into the into the escape
pod of lag now then I gotta go oh god oh
oh my god oh my god I need to make ah
goddamnit a table coral dot that coral I
need to make water
oh my god is so laggy I have no idea why
but also I need to make food I need to
drink water I have to take care of
myself I need the hydrate
I got table coral and not the right
coral at least you know I'm gonna make
that gosh darn computer chip then I've
gotta go get some oh I can make an
advanced wiring kit I probably need no I
needed the computer chip [ __ ] god damn
it okay I'll be back
[ __ ]
you know let's let's let's pull a
mulligan on the beginning of this video
I'm gonna let's all assume that this
isn't the beginning and let's just start
on forward to the actual beginning huh
Wow why are you green whoa whoa whoa it
was green is that the effect of the
virus no way
it's green holy [ __ ] it's green that
legitimately means I'm pretty sure
that's legitimately
the virus having its way with these visa
the fauna here oh my god they're green
too everything's dying I should probably
do something about that we're not at the
beginning of the episode yet everybody
go back it's not time
dinner's not ready don't come into the
kitchen when mommy's cooking is
markiplier losing his mind in the deep
ocean the answer is yes excessively ha
now that everyone knows I'm absolutely
out of my gourd Oh welcome back to
subnautica so right now we're gonna go
back to the wreck by the mushroom forest
and we're gonna collect what belongs to
us and what belongs to us is one more
PDA with a little bit more story in it
and then another design for the rest of
the vehicle modification station which
is something that I absolutely yes 100%
need if I don't have that what the [ __ ]
was that
excuse me what the [ __ ] is that
oh oh I forgot I dumped that because I
needed some goodies oh okay well whoops
found that again how and what are the
odds of me finding that one thing that I
dumped oh well my [ __ ] god damn it
[ __ ] off with your [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
yeah I forgot I've got names to read I
don't have lockers yet because I don't
have via gonna have the new base built
but I've got names
so phantom said if you make a seamoth
perimeter defense system which sounds
[ __ ] awesome it's easier to get past
the Reaper Leviathan it activates when
they try to grapple the ship it'll shock
them and then they'll let go there's so
that's pretty cool but I have no idea
how to make that the general said sorry
there's no way to deactivate the gun yet
no matter what the Sun beam gets shot
down like me whenever I flirt with a
girl at least the Sun chick beam getting
shot down looks cool so I'm gonna put
the general once I do get my bass back
that comment is frickin amazing and
hilarious and I love it but I'm not
gonna be able to get to that until I
beat it until I get that just soon so
hopefully there's none right near me and
then a bean echo who said I missed a PDA
at the crash site so thank you for that
I wouldn't have known oh well handy vas
well would you look at that I've got the
vehicle modification station that's good
for me so I'm just gonna sneak in here
real quick because I did miss PDA so
i'ma try to see I [ __ ] well depth
reached thanks Karen I know take care of
it I know it's a tight squeeze but
squeeze into it you must okay so there
was apparently a PDA around here
somewhere that I'd gone missed ah I
think you're missing the handle just a
little bit there buddy Oh
Oh secret double door hooter known ah
this abandoned PDA profitability
projections well I'm sure there's a lot
of goodies here but I'm also sure
there's a lot of dead E's here
as in crew members in family members and
everyone else they're all they're all
quite dead okay Sabu's key okay I got
what I needed there so now that I got
that I'm all good I've got what I needed
I got what I came for I'm gonna read the
PDA entry on the way back and then I'm
gonna cut forward to when I've already
got the materials for my base I'm not
gonna make you wait any longer on that
one but then I'm gonna go get the
materials and then get to the point
where I'm ready to make my new base
sound good all right we'll do that
oh [ __ ] we got it oh I think I know what
that one's all about yeah I think I know
all right anyway two choices Hey carry
on working long all missions on the
outer reaches base B come up with
profitable business sell out to Altera
live happily ever after I choose B ideas
a robot that builds other robots a laser
cutter the determinant battery life
solar power a phase gate that can be
built by self repairing robots instead
of for lonely humans on an 18-month
mission a VR program that precisely
simulates real life down to the finest
detail how do I know they didn't already
invent it we're inside it right now a
gun that shoots other smaller guns huh
those are fantastic ideas I love that
okay so I'll be right back
Wow oh my god ow my ass
Karen Jesus I told you to ask permission
first oh boy oh boy
sunbeam broadcasting to all survivors of
the aurora we've covered more than half
the distance Oh hold on in there we're
scanning the planet for dry land as we
speak you couldn't have picked a less
convenient parking spot though we'll be
in touch as soon as we have a landing
site for you Sunday mount yeah that's a
bad idea don't do that oh boy they're
all dead aren't they they're gonna be
very dead don't go nowhere okay I got it
hi dad I got a deploy this hurt oh my
god deploy put
hey never deployed you pair day oh [ __ ]
oh that's so cool
I'm gonna call you the general that the
general ah I like it okay where'd all my
titanium go I do not like being in this
goddamn creepvine forest hooah
yeah yeah it sucks
oh yeah I like the way this sucks
making some Lube making some Lube making
a whole lot oh okay what the hell
happened
mine this moved again I'm never gonna be
able to find the general you moved why
did you move why are you moving so much
you asked your bag of ass dicks you bag
of butthole douches you bag of bingo
longers you bag of douche your donors
okay but either way I have four ingots I
have six Titanium's
I've got food I'm going to have water
I'm going to have more water I will have
food and we'll be good to go okay good
enough so we got that now I I have for
those four Louvre's I got the computer
chip I got all that stuff I got titanium
what else do I need for a moon pool whoa
that's a lot of stuff oh nice I like it
I like it a lot I unlocked a lot of
upgrades I like it I like it a lot okay
but I'll need more computer chips once I
get that but I'll worry about that when
I get to it I just want to build
everything first and then be good so
I've got everything I've got everything
I just need to find my goddamn general
box so if you could you know come out of
hiding I didn't put a [ __ ] beacon on
yeah I see you oh I see you okay now the
general is this gonna be
Delon out here forever floating adrift
in the sea never to be seen from again
oh well so sad okay is that enough
quartz I don't think so I think I'll
need one more I need I'd probably enough
okay
hello welcome back okay so if you've
been wondering where we've been all this
time we've been flipping in and out of
existence but now we're good and we're
back and we're ready to make what we
need to do I have literally all the
materials necessary to be able to build
a base where I need to build it and
it'll be my permanent deep sea base that
I love and cherish and hold very dear
and also it'll be a hue it'll be a good
launching point for me to be able to
send off ish to be sent able to send off
into the dark deep depths and also I
know for a fact there is a entrance
[ __ ] stop hitting my goddamn SEMA I
know
whoa I know there's an entrance into the
inactive lava zone from the deep reef
I've gone through it I've done it before
I've gone through the deeper areas so I
know for a fact it exists and so once I
built my moon pool and once I'm able to
do all that stuff and once I'm able to
get my launching point necessary I will
be able to go down deep
into the inactive lava zone from this
point but I have to build the base first
and I'm gonna do that I am going to do
that if it'll stop lagging can actually
get me where I need to go and stop thee
you know ominous death choir that I
don't enjoy then I'll be able to do what
I need to do but until then I am off
where was that platform is that's it oh
yeah that's it okay this is a good
platform I think this is a good
launching boss for me well that was a
new noise was a new noise oh that was
that was a sea trip I remember you
okay you carry on and be a bag of dicks
about everything I'm gonna build my base
you got to get a foundation first prime
this is everything
if this isn't right then nothing's gonna
be right really
add caboose key okay then we get a
multi-purpose room right on the
precipice of destruction and then I'm
gonna overlook the moonpool off on this
southern edge it'll be just like that
pool oh baby oh baby baby oh baby baby
yes oh baby did they make the moon pool
bigger it looks bigger it looks a lot
bigger maybe I should move my seamoth
out of the way first probably a good
idea
Thank You chef Sookie it's a-comin
there is oil just that quickly molecular
stabilization I love this tool table
just it
reassign everything for me and boom Oh
baby
yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah oh hell
to the yeah now I don't think I'm gonna
be able to make the art think I'm gonna
be able to make the uh via
whatchamacallit yet
oh it's unpowered I forgot to power it
cuz I'm a goddamn idiot
oh I'm sack of [ __ ] all that I can build
that I could also build the thermal but
I don't know after weeks without human
contact it's normal to experience
psychological discomfort research
indicates symptoms may be partially
alleviated by adopting a pet or
anthropomorphizing
inanimate object I'm good at sack I get
this is this is big blue Paul berry uh
oh that's that's that's oblong pillar
Arnold
Oh your Spadefish super duper ooper I'm
about to die
I don't know oxygen Nikolas all right so
I need to get this place powered but I
don't think a thermal generators gonna
be very good for that yeah I'm just
gonna go with basic power let's just do
one of these it's not gonna give me
anything [ __ ]
well there's basically no way there's
power down here oh no I forgot about the
hatch I don't have glass oh I'm an idiot
oh [ __ ] oh no I guess I can get in this
way emergency power only well oxygen
production offline well that's that's
not good
well there seems to be some oxygen here
that seems to be a little bit it seems
to be able to let's do it okay
it's a struggling a little bit but you
know I could forgive it it's all right
all right so I'm gonna have the
fabricator away from the moonpool
acting bugger good eye right there
there's enough it's not a lot of power
but I mean it's enough okay so I got
that that's good I like that that's good
stuff like that great love it good then
I need everything because I have nothing
aha you know the other challenging thing
that I got to do is I've got a wok or
I've got to swim all the way to my Miya
Miya prawn suit over there and then I've
got to walk it all the way back over
here okay all right I'm back I'm over
here at my other base and I have my
buddy boo here
we've captain thanks Bob ah so hopefully
hopefully I'll be able to get this thing
back but what I wanted to do beforehand
because I have essentially screwed
myself over but it's okay you know it's
alright is it's not that bad it's not
that bad
no I'm not I'm not mom little fruit so I
got a look and see what I've got in
these uh in these employed places and
I'm pretty sure I've got some goodies so
I just need to take the goodies and
utilize the goodies Oh water here who'da
thunk it
Oh who didn't knew it oh whoops didn't
mean to do that
bloody lastik oh I just drank water why
did that hurt me [ __ ] you it's important
to note the solar panels will work
they just won't work well so I'll have
them but they just won't do a lot so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
disassemble one of these well dis
constructed cuz I don't need this much
power over here I can use the quartz and
then I'm gonna walk my little guy here
all the way over to the other place whoo
whoo I like it I like it
I've asked it it pounced [ __ ] get
powned Supes I get grabbed apparently
everybody want to get the pouched it's
weird seeing the ocean from like the
floor level
hardly ever I'm able to come down here
so just walking through it like this is
just bizarre
well hello what's that
whoa okay all the sudden hello how you
doing hey will will will
hey wait oh ah load I think I think that
actually might be if I'm not it's a
bioreactor hell yeah
hey yeah oh yeah I think I need Lube for
that but that's not important I got what
I got I got what I got that's good I
don't have the space for lube but I
gotta build lockers first oh hello you
want to get pounced a punch dafuq out to
you
i'ma get punched [ __ ] yeah that's right
run away you don't know you're up
against and it's me that you're up
against kiss you with the obvious oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy weird seeing you
from the bottom oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay here we go home boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy not used to this
yeah [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
poor girl is hot here okay I need this
though need this need this need this now
it's very hot here well maybe I can make
a oh I'm right by oh maybe I can make a
Thermal generator whoa whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
hello [ __ ] the sack
would you put my goddamn thing
go [ __ ] that's where to go [ __ ] you know
I don't like that I like that I don't
like I one bit their book dip another
storage goddammit [ __ ] that and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you I'm outta here baby [ __ ] I
don't know where my base is but [ __ ]
that oh don't go down there I'll never
come back up
come on thrust make it thrust butthole I
am lost I'm scared and I am alone except
I'm not alone I've got a horrible
monstrosity that I believe is the warper
that's trying to kill me so that's
comforting I just gotta get back here
where the illuminated balls are but I
was driven away from the balls by the
son-of-a-bitch warper way I see balls up
there so maybe those balls are my balls
I gotta find my balls oh yay I found it
oh that took way longer than it should
have but alas I found it and I've
brought my monstrosity that is my
goddamned prawn okay but I don't have a
seam off so she'd oopsy poopsy here we
go hey it oh there's no power oh ha ha
ha ha ha ha but I got a bioreactor and
nothing to build it with ah you'll just
stay right here and you've got a beak
did you so I'll see you watch I hahahaha
I am dying warning hey how about Li
oxygen production woo okay I'm a happy
guy okay so anyway I'm all out of time
I've been playing for about an hour now
I have made a couple errors but hey I've
got the moonpool
it may be unpowered and I may not have
my seamoth with me but hey at least I
got spirits so that's all that matters
so thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this [ __ ]
showing of an episode but I had some fun
and ran into a new character on the way
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye